is going on everybody welcome to one of
the most requested python videos to date
and that is dedicated to the meshing of
python with interactive brokers or ib
using ibp pi
so ibr interactive brokers is a broker's
appears to take the middle ground
between institutional training and
individuals and maybe not even the
middle ground they pretty much appeal to
both parties and a wide spectrum so to
play with interactive brokers we only
need to have a demo account and for a
real trading account the minimum is ten
thousand dollars which is actually quite
low um for someone who offers these
similar services
so the demo is only going to support a
small number of trading like symbols
like stock symbols and all of that but
you'll definitely get the idea and once
you have a an approved and funded
account you'll be able to use
interactive brokers paper trader which
is kind of like ib's paper trading tool
that gives you a sense of you know
how you can fully mimic live trading
without the risk right so paper trading
but first we can just play with the demo
and decide if this is really a path that
we want to go down so
first we want to go ahead and set up the
demo so the first thing we need to do is
head over to https cool
www.interactivebrokers.com
let me bring mine up
once you're here
what you're going to want to do is head
over to open an account then go to
individuals because that's us
and then we don't want either of these
but we want platform demo so you'll
click on that
and then you want to come here to try
individual demo for trader workstation
what that's going to do is download a
file right here just hit keep
and it should be edema edema dot jnlp
if you don't get it you should be able
to see if tw yeah if this fails to
download you can click here that's going
to open up this one
and i would still use the standalone you
can use the browser-based one but i
would just i would actually kind of
recommend this standalone
and do that or mac unix whatever you
need but this should work out for you so
you click on that
and that'll make this pop up now mine i
don't think it'll end up asking me but
if this is your first time it's going to
ask you whether or not you want to use
the old
look
or the new look
and the new look is like mosaic and then
the old look i don't even know what they
call it but anyway i'm going to be using
mosaic so if you want to follow along
exactly and it look like mine looks use
mosaic
so once that's done let's see i got
here's a little some of these warnings
sometimes we'll hit okay there and we
don't want to open an account so let's
hit close so what should pop up is this
so you've got this interactive brokers
kind of platform going on here
so
most of these the only two things we're
really going to look at this has prices
over here
this has your portfolio
um
and then any orders you have here but
you can always go like portfolio you can
change this stuff up right and both
these are now showing orders anyway this
is the traders workstation you can play
around with it if you want this isn't
really our main focus the only thing i
would like to add
is
sometimes they just throw random things
it seems into your portfolio
so when you load up sometimes you might
have pure cash sometimes you might have
um some sort of forex
or you know foreign money
you got stocks or whatever but generally
you're going to have about 500 000
uh dollars in your account so sometimes
you'll see other stuff here and it can
get kind of confusing if it's your first
time but just know that some for
whatever reason they throw random stuff
in there or maybe i'm doing something i
don't realize but it does seem like it's
just kind of random when you open it up
so now the only other thing that we need
to do
while we're here is we want to go to
file
global configuration that'll bring up
this window here
when you're here click on api
and then go to settings
now once you're in settings you should
see a screen that looks something like
this
make sure you have enable activex and
socket clients checked and down here you
just want to note this number it should
be the same for everybody 7496
and then you want to come down to master
api client id you want to specify some
sort of client id for us let's just say
we're 999. that's all i'm going to say
and when you're done there just go ahead
hit apply
okay and we're all set
and the other thing you might want to
check let's go
file global configuration again api
precautions and make sure you have this
checked bypass order precautions for api
orders
and
again hit apply okay
that should be the only settings that we
need to set now that we've got the
trader workstation up and the api in
theory there even though you didn't
really have to set much up it's there
the next thing that we need to do is we
want to get ib pi so we can interact
with this with python because the actual
tws api is actually a java api so you're
supposed to be using java and what ibpi
is is basically it's just a python
wrapper around the java api
so um so that's what we want to get next
so once you're ready for that you want
to head over to github.com
p slash ib pi
i will put the links to all this stuff
in the description
and once you're here if you are on
windows anyways uh just download the zip
file
and if you're on you know linux or
whatever you can use the git and all
that but anyway
once you've got it installed let's go
ahead and
open that up show the folder
and here we have our e demo and then
here's our ib pi master it's obviously
zipped up so let's go ahead and extract
it
and that gives us this this okay so now
what we want to go ahead and do is
come back here hold shift right click
open command window here
and now what we want to run is a
setup dot pi
install so we want to install ivy pi so
once you've done that ivy pi is now
installed and you're ready to use ivy pi
so now we're done with this so we can
close this out we can close out of here
and we don't need our browser anymore i
don't think unless i've screwed
something up go ahead and leave your ib
tws up and active at least i guess i'll
just leave it well
i'll just minimize it for now but we'll
come back to it don't worry
so now we're ready to actually start
programming
uh with ivy pie now i think it would be
useful at least to explain real quick
because i get a lot of questions about
this
and
there's obviously a whole lot we can do
with ivy pie
because ibupy pretty much has everything
you want to do with the api so i mean
this is options you've got
different order types just everything
that you might be able to do with the
api you can do without be pie so if you
if there's something you're looking for
chances are you can find it if you head
over um
go to your python directory so generally
that's going to see
python27 or python34 or whatever
and once you're there head over to lib
and i said python 34 but i don't pretty
sure ivy pi ibpi is like i don't think
an active development anymore so i don't
think it's going to work on three but
anyway
lib
site packages and you'll find ib
ivy pi is under ib and then in here is
where you're going to find all the stuff
that this does so this is where
connection how you make the connection
to their server and then i want to say
it's going to be an extension
and then yeah anything like make orders
you've got market data
contract we use
and basically all this stuff you know so
you can look through it and see what
what's all available to you if you have
something specific you could look
through the documentation but what i'm
going to do is have us walk through just
a simple
how do we make orders so how do we
either buy a stock at market or buy
stock at a limit offer or sell or
whatever so that's what we're going to
cover here
so to begin from ib dot opt we want to
import
connection and also we want message
and connection so we can connect message
is actually we're probably going to use
message in this one i just want to keep
this pretty simple but when you
speak to and from the server it's going
to give you back a message and so if
you're having errors or trouble it can
be helpful to like print out what the
message was
so the next thing that we want is from
iv.x dot contract
we want to import
contract
and then finally from ib.exed.order
we want to import order so we're going
to connect we set up a contract and then
we place the order for that contract
so first let's go ahead and make this
contract so we're going to define
make
contract
and in order to make a contract we need
the following things
we have to have a symbol so in this case
what's the stock symbol
then you also when you're making a
contract you have to have a security
type so we're going to just do sec
type
then you have to specify on what
exchange
under what primary exchange
and then the currency
those are all the parameters that we
need it's now ready to
specify what we want to do with those
parameters because actually the making
of a contract as i just showed you is
done completely by ibypi we don't have
to do any programming we just have to
feed it to ibpi so to do that now we're
going to say
contract.m
underscore
symbol and this is in reference again to
ib pi so m underscore symbol can be
found in the contract function
of
um
inside ib slash
ib x and then contract is going to be in
there and that will be the actually not
contract function that'll be it's
contract.pi in there and then m symbol
in there so anyway if you want to look
more at the documentation for that just
keep that in mind so anyway what i was
just saying here
extension and then you have
extension contract
and then if you were to open this up
you're going to find this contract class
and that's what it's talking about so
all these things are a possibility right
when making a contract so you can see
there's a whole lot of possibilities
here
anyway closing out of this
moving this aside so contract out m
symbol that's going to be equal to
symbol
then
contract dot m underscores sec type
equals set type
contract dot
m
underscore
exchange equals x
contract dot
m underscore
primary
x
equals prim
and then we finally have currency so
contract dot m underscore currency
equals curve
and then finally at the end of this we
just return
contracts
and that's it for make contracts so all
we're really doing is passing through
some variables through the already
created class of contract for us
so now we've got a contract now we need
to make the order now
when you make an order at least to me
you generally at least with stocks
you've got you know you've got your
market order where you want it to
basically be an instant order and then
you've got a limit order
so you can do one of two things you can
either we could have make market order
or make limit order functions
specifically or we can kind of set it up
to the point where one function covers
it all
and so the way i'd like to do that is so
define make underscore order
and then we're going to have action
so action will correspond to are we
buying or selling
and then we're going to have
quantity
and quantity is going to be how many are
we buying or selling
and then we're going to have price
how much do we want to pay per
and to start we're going to have price
be a default of none
and
maybe you can see where i'm going with
this but if price is not
none
this means we
specified a price
so the next things that we want to do is
order equals order and order is
corresponding to
ib.x.order
order so it's going to be the order
class so again
x and then we come down here to order
just so we can see what we're working
with
and this is the order again there's a
lot of
different parameters that we can talk or
specify here
even more than the other one so anyway
look through that if you've got specific
order types and stuff that you want to
do
but anyway order equals order
now we're going to say order dot m
underscore order
type
and that is going to be equal to well if
if the price is not none that means we
specified a price
so
if we specified a price then this must
be a limit order so we specify a limit
order with a capital lmt
now next order.m underscore
total
quantity
that's going to equal quantity
and then order.m underscore action
equals action whatever we say so that's
buy or sell
and then finally order dot m underscore
limit
or sorry lmt capital p-r-i-c-e
and that equals price
and that's it for a limit offer now what
if we didn't specify well then we have a
market offer or a market order so now
i'm just going to copy this
paste it down here this remains first
line remains the same this changes to
mkt for market
total quantity stays quantity action
stays the same this time we just don't
specify a limit price
that's that
now we're all done with make oh my
goodness i just noticed i call this make
under
make order that's uh quite the typo
anyway now at the end of this we want to
return
order
and now we're done
next uh what we want to have here
is some sort of
i guess we'll call this a main a main
loop for now
oops define main
and under main we're gonna have con for
connection equals capital c connection
dot create
and here you have to specify the port
and the client id support and that's
equal to that number i pointed out
earlier so it's 74.96 most likely for
all of you and then also client
id
and we said that was 999.
so then we run con.connect
and now we'll have established a
connection and when you run this
in this
tws here is going to come up with a
pop-up and it says you want to authorize
this connection so you'll have to hit
okay and at that point you'll fully
connect it
now the next thing that we have here is
an order id
so
normally you'll make your connection and
let's say you're going to make a lot of
trades you're going to run this over a
long period of time you're going to need
to add some sort of counter function
that each time it loops through each
time it makes a trade it gives plus one
to this value so for now we'll say order
id equals one
but eventually you have to change that
and just like increment it up
so now what do we want to do well we
first we want to specify the contract so
we'll use const just so we don't
interfere with the name contract and con
equals make underscore contract
and
what contract do we want to make so
let's go back up to make contract here
we've got symbol security type exchange
primary exchange currency
so
first we had symbol let's trade uh let's
do tesla so that's tsla
and what is tesla well tesla is a stock
and to denote stock it's stk
then we have to specify the exchange in
the primary exchange well we're going to
use smart
and then again
smart
now you can actually specify what
exchange
smart is interactive brokers smart
routing and what they do is they will
automatically choose where your order
should be routed to based on
price and also
where is this order actually going to be
able to be executed so price and
availability
and then the final thing that we specify
here is currency and we'll say us
dollars
so we've made the contract now we're
ready to actually execute this contract
so our offer
is oops let's get rid of caps here offer
equals
make underscore order
and for now
um
the easiest thing would be let's make a
let's make a limit offer first so we
want to buy
how many shares do we want to buy let's
just say one
and at what price because this is a
limit so if we said by one and just left
it like this
then it would mark it by one share of
tesla but we can specify a price and now
it's now will become a limit offer for
us
fancy dancy stuff here and now we're
ready to place this so let's do con dot
place order
and the parameters here are going to be
order id so oid which is one at the
moment
and then we want to say the contract and
then our offer
and that's it now when you're all done
you have to run a con.disconnect
this connect
and that's it
now hopefully the only thing i see maybe
the order ideal conflict but i think
once you restart um tws that won't
conflict now that should be it now just
a couple of things i've noted in
my time playing with this
is first of all what is this i don't
even know what this is
i'm gonna move this over
um in my time playing with this for
whatever reason sometimes your offer
uh just doesn't come through
so like try like four or five times
before you give up hope um because for
whatever reason sometimes it just
straight up doesn't come through for me
for whatever reason and i assume it's
just you know this is a demo and so it's
just not the perfect thing and also like
i said sometimes like weird things
happen like you just randomly buy stuff
like i didn't buy any microsoft and i
don't know why that's there
anyway
um
let's go ahead and run this see what
happens so we'll save it let's run it
oh we have to call main of course
and here's our accept the incoming
connection attempt we'll hit yes
and sec type not define let's go look at
what we've done
okay so
we said that let's say this instead
let's
i don't think i'd have to increment that
so we'll try and get away with not let
me call main at the bottom here
run it accept the connection
and
looks like we made the connection
and but there was no offer that i see
here because we did want a limit offer
let's raise order id to 2
send it through one more time
now just out of curiosity i want to say
order id like 500
maybe it's conflicting with previous
order right okay so i guess for me it
was just conflicting with previous order
ids so i guess it does save your order
id
whenever you close it
not positive it might have just randomly
come back but i'm pretty sure that's the
case so let's go we could say like 501
now
and see like now it doesn't come in i
just don't get it sometimes
uh
that's what i mean with the demo i'm not
really sure how you can like improve
this or why this is actually occurring
sometimes i'm curious to know if their
actual like service is better than this
if you're not using the demo account i
sure would hope so but uh
anyway so that should work for everybody
you should be able to make your
connection now um
i imagine there's like a lot of little
stuff that could interfere with this
because you're not actually like there's
no like
api connection there's no login
happening here so i'm not really sure
like it's a very s pseudo
api connection that they have here this
is the easiest demo i've ever played
with with an api so
anyway there it goes again so
i don't know what to why this does it
this way but anyways
that's it with the basics for ivy pie
with interactive brokers and all of that
if you have any questions or comments
feel free to leave those below uh well i
guess one more thing i'll show you guys
just just for kicks the market order so
let's call this 503.
hopefully it'll run it
for whatever reason it didn't let's try
it again
there it goes
if anybody happens to know why it
appears to be random feel free to let me
know
anyway if you have any questions or
comments feel free to leave them in the
section below if you have any requests
for another specific trade or
something like that that to use ibpi
with or the api with
feel free to make some requests below if
you have them as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time